our play mark hey Mark I came all the
way out here to see you I missed you you
want to hang out yeah wait
that's why I flew you to LA get in here
you freaking weirdo
hey guys guess who decided to stop by
and not be a total creeper weirdo and
like doorstep lazier hey guys that's
indigo are gonna be here tomorrow
and we're gonna be able to go and have a
lot of fun and make a lot of cool games
press your button big egos all week long
gameplay sketch comedy you name it sweet
talk about I just replaced bad that's
not a good thing so a nice Bob and
synagogue both going to be here tomorrow
and they're going to be joining us for
even more games even more fun games
anymore so thanked him for a week full
of fun
oh also yeah boy we have real time
playing video game dude
this videos probably on roids faces dawn
my face cuz somewhere there's a video is
here there's you click to see the video
right now Cinco de prank oh it's almost
over because it's almost tomorrow oh oh
so expect more silliness coming on the
future
present first before you do I'm not
doing anymore
so anyway then you get everybody sounds
are watching and as always we'll see you
in the next video
cut me off guard we did it in 1000 man
I'm sweating some bucks no that's what
it did leave later the thing one calls
me just a sweat profusely we can just
unstoppably why do you own this so you
and I can do these videos together a lot
of fun yes fun one do you alright what's
actually doing turn green and whenever
it turns green whoever president first
doesn't get shocked over his high stakes
and
the price for your screw-up
train sucking dick all day long my head
probably mess stroke into your [ __ ]
doing hi-ho hi-ho it's off this up we go
be sure to get the balls huh a little
double dutch bass